i appreciate you having me um
so for the people listening and watching
who may not know
uh basically your son is
ross ulbricht who i believe at the age
of 31
uh had created a billion dollar
e-commerce website called silk road and
is now serving two life sentences for it
that just got a couple of errors um okay
just to straighten
that out okay of all he was 26
he wasn't 30 um and
it wasn't a billion dollars although
that is often said
in the media which is completely
inaccurate the government's
own estimate of everything on the silk
road legal and illegal and everything
else
was 183 million 180
you know billion is a thousand million
right 183 million is a
far cry from a billion and often they'll
say over a billion is not accurate
and i'm just going by the government's
own um stats
so so is it just the headlines in the
media that are saying a billion or was
it the actual
was it the government who said it was
over a billion the government said 183
million
um that's yeah the it's the media
the media you know echoing each other
with false information which happens
all too frequently so how did this whole
story begin for you with ross and and
what he was doing and can you just give
me
from your perspective how this whole
thing unraveled
and how long ago did this happen
2013 ross is arrested in november
sorry october 1st 2013
and his father and i found out about it
from reuters a reuters reporter called
us
we had no clue and um
yeah i mean and then all of everything
hit the fan
and um you know all kinds of media were
coming by the house and they were saying
ross was involved with murder for hire
which was inconceivable and still is
and he was never charged with that a
trial by the way and um
and it just became a complete maelstrom
of stuff and that's my life's never been
the same since
basically that was pretty much it on um
it was actually october 2nd when we
found out he was arrested october 1st
from i found out from a reuters reporter
who called us
how close were you and ross during that
time
or like the years leading up to that
well ross was living in california i was
living in
austin texas and um in costa rica where
we had have business so my husband and i
so um we were close
and you know everything and on good
terms and
you know and always were but we weren't
living in the same state even so
you know my and i wasn't with my
daughter either i mean they both you
know are doing their thing
did you have any idea like what he was
doing for a living did he talk to you
about like how he made his money
what he was what he was doing every day
he had a uh he had a book business in um
austin an online book business uh called
good wagon books and actually he
he contributed 10 percent or so to
charity local charities um from that
business
and um a friend um
renee pannell said hey come on out to
california where i am he
ross was ready to move on from the
business and um
he said i want to get into some venture
capital stuff and some startups and i
want you to be involved and
and like that so he went uh out to
california
and was looking into that kind of thing
um
that's what uh that's my understanding
of what he was doing at that time
he did tell he did say that he created
he was very on fire for freedom he was
very
involved with the ron paul campaign in
2008 and he
brought ron paul to penn state when he
was there as a
graduate student and um became very
um passionate about free markets and
about bitcoin which
um and the potential for monetary
freedom with bitcoin
and told me about bitcoin in fact i even
said should i get some and he said no
mom it's too volatile and i'm like
wow it was probably about 50 cents then
okay anyway that was a mistake
and um in any case um he was very
passionate about that
and free markets and he wanted to bring
those principles and experience to
people and he
he created a video game to that end but
uh didn't get it published
and then uh turned to the internet and
created
the silk road website which was based on
the non-aggression principle
of strictly voluntary interaction no
force
didn't uh strictly forbidden were things
and this is all acquiring the government
as well
uh things that harmed a third party so
if two people want to exchange something
and it and it doesn't harm a third party
it was pretty much
permitted from my understanding but if
it did
harm a third party for instance child
porn it was not allowed because that
hurts a child
on so many levels right or stolen
property that hurts the owner of the
property
so those things were not permitted it
was strictly by the non-aggression
principle
which is basically a libertarian
principle
drugs were permitted um you know it was
considered a free choice among
individuals mostly user amounts of
cannabis was what
was exchanged on the site and um
so yeah so he started that and uh
yeah so silk road was basically just i
didn't know about it i didn't know a
thing about it i mean it just you know
until he was arrested
right i mean essentially what he created
was just a platform where people could
buy and sell goods uh an agreement
between
a buyer and a seller that kept
anonymity and they could and they would
use bitcoin and they would be able to
maintain complete uh
keep themselves anonymous essentially
yeah that was the point and
there were a lot of legal things
exchanged you don't hear about that ever
but um
you know uh books and art and uh
electronics and you know the whole list
and it's on our
i sent the link and actually maybe you
guys are going to put it up but there's
a whole
and our website also has it uh of a lot
of things that were listed
it's kind of like an ebay but it was you
know private and
it um actually plenty of people sell
drugs on ebay too so
but you know is more open about that
exactly it was ebay it was basically an
ebay that you had to jump through a few
extra hoops to get on it and
use it yeah you had to open a bitcoin
account you had to fund
the bitcoin account and you had to know
how to use tor
right because bitcoin was the only um
you know currency
permitted on the site which is why ross
has so much support among
the cryptocurrency community because
really his vision
brought you know put it on the map
bitcoin would not be worth i looked
today
18 000 uh if
it weren't for ross really bringing it
making it prove itself as money and um
i've been told by people in the
community that he's the second most
important person in bitcoin history
after satoshi nakamoto who created
bitcoin
so um yeah so that was his vision but
ross's intention
was always for freedom and privacy
and the individual he's very you know
feels very strongly about that
and yeah that's what his intention was
it wasn't to be
a drug kingpin and actually
as a side thing the judge judge forrest
who gave him that
barbaric sentence basically a death in
prison sentence
for all non-violent charges she said at
sentencing
we know that you started the site for
philosophical reasons
so she knew he wasn't a drug kingpin i
don't think el chapo or pablo escobar
that philosophical i just that's just my
guess
um they do it for money and power right
ross was doing it for philosophical
reasons
and she said but i'm just not sure it's
a philosophy you've left behind
and basically she's saying for that if
you haven't given up that philosophy of
voluntary interaction
and um you know do no harm to third
party and
non-aggression principle i'm gonna have
to condemn you to die in a cage
that's basically what she said in so
many words